here now with a look at what is ahead
and those impeachment hearings is
Washington Post national correspondent
Phillip Phillip good morning morning
let's start broad picture here we start
these public hearings on Wednesday what
are the Democrats hoping to get out of
this because obviously we've started to
see some of those transcripts from the
closed-door hearing already all right
well I think what they're what they're
hoping to get here is to have these
people speaking publicly get it on
television and have people in America be
more broadly aware of what it is that
they're saying right I mean I think the
question is the impeachment polling sort
of stagnant at this point or spiked
after the inquiry began it hasn't really
changed much since then Democrats really
want to see that move the question is
how will this becomes covered in
conservative media in particular will it
be aired regularly or not I think that
remains to be seen swamps former
national security advisor John Bolton
has indicated that he may know there was
something something about Ukraine and
he's willing to testify just as long as
the judge orders him to do it right what
can we make of this really sure I think
we make a couple things of it first of
all the John Bolton very much an
institutionalist he doesn't want to just
go out there and say I'm gonna ignore
executive privilege and adhere to what
the House wants to do he really does see
this probably as a legal fight between
these two branches of government wants
the courts to settle that of course he
knows what happened right I mean he was
in the room for some of these meetings
he was the guy who is ostensibly in
charge of what was happening from the
White House's end on foreign policy so
there's certainly things that he knows
and that may actually influence the
courts to say you know what executive
privilege in this case doesn't even
apply because this is so important but
couldn't get immunity well I mean I
don't know if there's any I don't think
there's any criminality that's suspected
by bold and I think it certainly is the
case though that he could offer a lot of
insight into what actually happened he
certainly is the key to all of this or
at least wants people that believe that
he's the key to all of this eight
depositions have been released so far
how is the public testimony gonna be
different than those eight depositions
that that also remains to be seen but I
think there are two ways the first is
since the depositions are already out
there the members of Congress who are
interviewing folks will have we much
better prepare they'll know exactly what
to expect what questions to ask to
elicit more information and I think the
witnesses themselves will probably be a
little bit more circumscribed they'll be
a little bit more nervous about offering
their opinions because this is televised
because this is open and I think it'll
be a lot more contentious one of the
names that we've seen besides Bolton
obviously
is Mick Mulvaney we've seen his name a
lot he didn't show up for his deposition
what do we know though that he knows
from other testimony right now all right
well he's gonna be an interesting case
and he actually the Post reporter this
morning he's joined that bolt lawsuit so
he's gonna wait and see what the courts
say he has to do as well he was very
much implicated in the testimony that
was released yesterday as having sort of
directed Ward and Salman bu ambassador
to take a lot of these actions I'd be
very interested if he is forced to
actually come testify whether he is very
open about what he knows I mean he
already admitted that there was a quid
pro quo last month essentially or if he
does this I don't know I don't remember
which is what song one did on the
interesting to see Mulvaney and Bolton
up there unlikely new time drama Phillip
um thank you very much a reminder CBS
News will bring you live coverage of the
impeachment hearings and testimony on
Wednesday and Friday morning